voici maintenant le document dont je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure c'est ce
reportage réalisé par robert bouchard
sur le front irakien et dans bagdad sous
les requêtes des chasseurs bombardiers
iranien des images tournées par à
l'arrêt de sa compagne de robert dantzer
de l'après midi la capitale irakienne
s'est installé dans la guerre et entre
deux bombardements
rien apparemment ne semble changer
pourtant chacun sait est pressant que la
journée ne se passera pas sans drame
cinq minutes plus tard tout est changé
le bruit des sirènes
pénet la ville qui s'affolent des
milliers de gens foncent dans tous les
sens à la recherche d'un abri
[Musique]
et puis c'est le grand silence bagdad
attend la ville retient son souffle
pas longtemps
le fantôme iraniens font sur la ville
passe entre deux antennes de télévision
épique sur la centrale thermique qui
fournit l'électricité à la capitale
[Applaudissements]
le raid a duré dix secondes
et voilà le résultat
[Musique]
jonathan
[Applaudissements]
g
et
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les hôpitaux déjà plaint des victimes
des raids précédents sont débordés
surtout des femmes et des enfants parmi
les blessés et les morts parce que les
hommes eux étaient à leur travail
bilan de ce raid onze morts 90 blessés
finalement la dc a fini par toucher
l'avion
le pilote que vous voyez en ce moment a
actionné son siège éjectable est tombée
aux mains des soldats irakiens
il essaye de se justifier il explique
qu'il voulait seulement détruire la
centrale électrique et que ce n'est pas
sa faute s'il y avait des maisons autour
l'avion lui s'est écrasé dans un terrain
vague le fuselage s'est enfoncé dans la
terre et à brûler seuls restent visibles
la queue de l'appareil nous en route
vers l'iran
sur le front nord est tout le long de la
route nous croisons des colonnes de
camions et blindés qui emmène des
renfort sur le front sud du côté de 40
chars et d'abats dans partout les
installations pétrolières ont été
détruites
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici à cassel frame nous sommes à 30 km à
l'intérieur du territoire iranien
sur ce front la victoire les irakiens
est indiscutable les troupes iraniennes
se sont peu battus et ont abandonné la
ville en laissant sur place munitions et
armement mais les iraniens sont en train
de se regrouper sur les pentes des
djebels qui barrent l'horizon
[Musique]
plus au sud c'est la route de meyrannes
une route elles aussi ont renvoyé par
les convois qui emmène des renforts vers
le sud
tout cela sans l'affolement on emmène
des renforts mais on ne sait pas
exactement où les mettre et on voit les
kilomètres de désert transformé en
immense parking pour radar char canon et
camions militaires
voici la petite ville de meyrannes
environ là aussi la victoire des
irakiens et complète mais elle s'est
faite sans combat lorsque les irakiens
sont entrés dans la ville
il ne restait plus qu'un habitant est
pas un seul soldat
[Musique]
plus au sud maintenant du côté de basra
dans la raffinerie brûle
nous sommes au bord du châtel arabes
dans la région qui résiste aux irakiens
ici ils n'ont pas pu traverser la
rivière les iraniens sont retranchés en
face à deux kilomètres devant à badens
les militaires irakiens disent qu'ils
vont tenter de franchir le pont cette
nuit alors nous restons avec eux mais à
peine ont-ils tenté d'avancer qu'un
déluge de bombes de mortier de balles de
mitrailleuses des clauses et aux aurores
les irakiens constateront que le pont a
été détruit
à badens ami guy raffinerie brûle
toujours ici l'implacable soleil du golf
n'est plus qu'une pâle étoiles on se bat
au canon et au mortier de chaque côté du
fleuve
et lorsque le vent du désert chasse la
fumée et que le soleil perce les coques
d'abadan royaume
alors il se met à chanter me comprenant
croient qu'ils peuvent ses ora
successives à la folie des hommes
ce journal est maintenant terminée